mobile had one hell of a year in 2016 it
continued to be an exciting diverse
amazing place to play games smartphone
games have long been the king of the
commute but then i drawing people's
attention away from their consoles at
home with some experiences you just
can't get anywhere else but enough talk
let's dig into the five best mobile
games of 2016 we start with severed a
game about a one-armed woman called
Sasha whose family get taken away from
her this may have the brilliant art of
the studio's last game guacamelee but
it's a much darker game to play part
dungeon crawling RPG part
point-and-click adventure part
first-person sword sim severed as a
mishmash of styles and skills but
somehow it works the frantic combat is
perfectly balanced by the more calm
exploration itself a welcome change for
some genuinely disturbing and affecting
moments the violence isn't always fun
if tales of death and violence are a bit
much then you might prefer the more
serene sights and sounds of mini Metro
spending your gaming time coordinating
people on hot crowded and uncomfortable
trains might not sound like the greatest
recreational activity ever especially
after a journey home spent on a hot
crowded uncomfortable train but make no
mistake mini Metro is amazing imagine
being the person in charge of designing
the London Underground and you're pretty
much there your network starts off slow
with just one line with a couple of
stops but it soon becomes a living
breathing pulsing beast which you're
responsible for what starts off as
relaxing background noise soon becomes a
hectic balancing act juggling trains and
bridges and carriages and new lines all
of which are in short supply it's a
surprisingly fantastic recreation of the
everyday commute the next game on this
list is called snake bird what a name
and what a game in some ways this is
similar to mini Metro the force you into
thinking it's just a bit of silly fun
it's got bright colors a goofy art style
and well there's a bird snake but
underneath is an extremely intelligent
and deeply challenging puzzle game
moving at 90-degree angles like in the
snake games on your Nokia brick you
guide your gravity ignoring Darwin
defying snake bird around spikes and
scenery to grab free fruit makes your
volley longer which will help you get to
each levels exit then the next level
will tax your brain a little bit more
reigns is sort of like tinder but only
for kings and queens unfortunately it's
not quite as entertaining as the
prospect of the Queen of England swiping
through a bunch of Jim lats but it's
still pretty good the aim of the game is
to live and well reign for as long as
possible by keeping four stats from
going too low or too high the church the
will of the people your army and your
money pot swiping is simply how you make
decisions in the text adventure parts do
you want to build a new hospital which
will benefit the people but cost you
money or would you rather keep the cash
and see illness rice careful though
monarchs with too much cash or too big
an army can suffer an untimely demise
but to describe reigns's text adventure
tinder doesn't do its depth justice
there are running gags hidden secrets
and story arcs that continue across
lives
lasting dozens or even hundreds of years
including one over a dog and a dungeon
you'll have to play it yourself to find
out more but just know that it can get
weird and that's why it's so wonderful
but no mobile game of the Year list
would be complete without Pokemon go
Pokemon girl was responsible for the
biggest buy of Pokemon fever since the
90s this summer and what a summer it was
the real world seemed to stop with
everyday worries replaced by how many
pages you'd be forced to look at today
or how much XP it would take to get to
level 20 Pokemon go was special because
it allowed you to carry out your
childhood dream of walking around your
own neighborhood to catch Pikachu and
battle out the monsters the social
element was also huge and a large part
of what made Pokemon go a success people
spoke to random strangers at gyms and
poker stops when they got to work or
school they will compare their cache of
the day they'd even go on Pokemon walks
together in a year where humanity seemed
to pull itself apart Pokemon goes
biggest success was that it brought
people together
[Music]
and I want to see you as high 21:38
[Music]